now then joining me for more on the
complexities of the german-american
relationship i'm joined by economist
Irving Collier is from the John F
Kennedy Institute for north american
studies here in Berlin is an expat who's
lived in Germany for more than two
decades so far good to have you here so
for more than two decades here in
Germany what brought you to Germany in
the first place well my research brought
me to Germany in the first place back in
the 70s I was a graduate student and had
the opportunity to be in East Germany
for seven months and my dissertation was
comparing the two germanys so from that
point on I had a dog in that fight I was
interested in how the economies of both
Germany's and after unification that was
one of the biggest questions for
economists it was curiosity that brought
you here which kept you here for more
than 20 years uh this I would say the
general standard of living lifestyle
lifework balance everything that you
want to do as a scholar you can do in
Germany or in my previous job at the
University of Houston in Texas but as
far as the quality of life is something
has no I I love Berlin I fell in love
with the city when I was a young man and
that's that first love uh was a hot one
I mean there are huge differences we
just seen it in the report this is
American entrepreneur and she said
failure doesn't exist for her the other
one was so much more cautious and there
of course a lot of US companies that are
household names in Germany how do you as
Americans define success well success
generally is to be the best in what you
do and you know I think if you were the
best hatchet murderer in the United
States should get respect because you're
the best it's a turn people look at life
as a tournament second place is just a
much smaller prize so when someone comes
up with the product a better mousetrap
it better be the best mousetrap